hello and welcome to the take with
safety rage live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster now it's hard to
believe but this time just seven days
ago we were asking whether Liz truss
could survive as prime minister well we
know the answer to that and now Rishi
sunak is in charge he's brought back the
fracking ban and delayed announcing
those spending cuts by another two weeks
and he faced difficult questions today
because the story we also covered on
this program just last week the
resignation of suello Brotherman over a
breach of the ministerial code or she is
now back as Home Secretary a week really
is a long time in politics he might have
done it to keep the right of his party
on side but has it damaged his claim
that the new government will be all
about integrity will bring you takes
from all sides over the next 60 minutes
the only time he ran in a competitive
election he got trounced by the former
prime minister who herself got beaten by
a lettuce
okay starmer went on the attack at pmq
he's calling for an immediate election
criticizing the new PM over the home
secretary's reappointment but
conservative MPS seemed generally
pleased with Rishi sunax responses
he talks about mandates about votes
about elections it's a bit Rich coming
from the person who tried to overturn
the biggest democratic
country's history
will there be much more of that to come
as the conservative party tries to pick
itself up after the last few months
we'll be seeing what potential voters
make of it all too when we speak to our
regular viewers panel there they are
hello everyone Little Wave looking
forward to speaking to you guys later
and on the show today we'll also be
talking to the conservative MP Maria
Caulfield Labor's Shadow International
Development Minister a prequel Gill plus
we'll be talking to the green party MP
Caroline Lucas and much more besides on
the take
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Keys earlier and there were some tough
questions on the reappointment of Zoella
Brotherman from kirst armor he repeated
his calls for general election and the
other big news today the chancellor
Jeremy Hunter said the big decisions on
public spending that we had been
expecting next Monday will now be
delayed by two weeks does that mean the
chancellor believes the markets are in
fact giving the new government a little
bit of breathing space well let's find
out we can crack straight on we're going
to start as usual with the best bits of
the week so far
it looks like uh penny mordant has
dropped out we have received one valid
combination
Richie sunac is therefore elected as
leader of the conceptual process the
outgoing prime minister Liz trust will
make a short farewell speech here
outside Downing Street it's not because
things are difficult that we do not dare
it's because we do not dare that they
are difficult
first glimpse of Richie sunac as prime
minister some mistakes were made and I
have been elected as leader of my party
and your prime minister
in part
to fix them Beth Rigby has just heard
that Jacob Reese MOG has resigned so
look Jeremy Hunt is the chancellor James
cleverly just confirmed as foreign
secretary Braverman is back as uh Home
Secretary he's not happy is she doesn't
look happy to me last few hours Richard
Cena's new cabinet came together for the
first time we've just heard
um that the Halloween budget has now
been delayed accuracy in the forecasts
is very important prime minister
the first British Asian prime minister
is a significant moment in our national
story he appointed a Home Secretary who
was sacked by his predecessor a week ago
at the homes actually made an error of
judgment but she recognized that she
raised the matter and she accepted her
mistake
a little bit of breaking news to bring
you now because we have had a few new
ministerial appointments that have just
come our way Anne-Marie trevellian you
know who backed of course Boris Johnson
as she was in the last cabinet she's a
minister of State in the foreign office
Chris philp who of course was a big Liz
trust backer to her former Chief
Secretary of the Treasury he's become a
minister of State in the home office and
then Steve Baker minister of State in
the Northern Ireland office he's stayed
in his job so he should be quite pleased
I think to stay in his job there in the
Northern Ireland office a couple of
people entering government which is seen
at backers people who were unhappy shall
we say with the direction under Liz
truss Alex chalk he's entered the
government again at Helen Whiteley Lucy
Fraser Greg hands Who was appointed by
Liz truss he's been reappointed in the
department for international trade so
certainly more indication shall we say
that Rishi sunak is building a
government from all the different wings
of the conservative party
well there'll be a few MPS who will be
perhaps still waiting for a call from
number 10 with the uh offer of a
ministerial job perhaps at our first
guest this evening Maria Caulfield who
is the MP for Lewis she was a health
Minister earlier in the year and she
joins us now um hoping for a call
yourself uh I'm very happy I've been uh
quite active on the back benches uh uh
kind of raising constituency issues so
um a bit quite busy as it is to be
honest fair enough uh so how big a break
do you think is the new prime minister
Rishi Scenic from Liz truss I think
think he is very different and I think
the public has seen that already I mean
for a start he's uh you know been quite
open about mistakes that have happened
in the last few weeks and I think the
public uh I think that find that a
refreshing change that politicians
saying you know we've got things wrong
but also that he is uh willing to put
that right but to make tough decisions
as well and to be open and honest with
people about that what decisions he's
going to have to make just like he did
during covid when you look at when he
was having to make decisions about who
to support financially as the chancellor
and who he couldn't support financially
so he's got a track record of being
really open and honest and taking the
tough decisions when they've needed to
be made you know you say he's a big
break and he obviously did say as you
say that mistakes were made under Liz
truss I guess some people might be
wondering why it looks like there's so
many familiar faces around the cabinet
table in that in that case you know it
doesn't really look like a fresh start
does it well I think you do need
experience because uh when she wants to
hit the ground running we've got huge
huge challenges facing the government
from the economic ones through to the
fact that we're heading into winter the
energy prices are going to be hitting
people's bills we've got the NHS that
always struggles every winter and so you
do need people who are experienced
ministers who know what needs to do know
how the system works I know uh what they
need to do as ministers to make the
difference that people feel quite
quickly and I think that's why rishi's
chosen such experience in his team one
of the people who perhaps is the most
controversial Zoella bribe I mean she
resigned from the cabinet after sending
an official document from her personal
email to another MP she then spent a
week one week on the back benches before
being reappointed by Rishi Cena I mean a
week on the back Ventures you know that
you take a week off work if you've got
the flu not if you've you know committed
a security breach what's going on well I
think as Wishy said at Prime Minister's
questions you know she was very open and
honest about that I'm very uh quick to
react when she realized she'd made a
mistake she apologized and she resigned
immediately for a week or for a week but
you know that was wasn't in her gift to
be reappointed and Rishi has accepted
her apology to accepted her explanation
and is confident in reappointing it you
know we've got track records under the
labor government we had Peter mandelson
who made mistakes twice and was
reappointed under Tony Blair and Gordon
Brown but he was still reappointed so
you know if you've made a mistake you've
acknowledged it and the explanation is
satisfactory then you know I I think
when she wants someone who's experienced
because again you know the small boats
issue is a big issue for
inconstituencies like mine on the south
coast and people want to see someone
who's able to get action happening as
quickly as possible so you're personally
comfortable then with her being
reappointed I don't know the details of
the mistakes she made I haven't seen her
explanation either but clearly wish she
has and he's comfortable and I think
that's the most important thing okay now
today number 10 refused to confirm
whether Rishi sunak is going to be
keeping the triple lock on pensions I
just want to have a look at a tweet you
put out on October 18th you said I will
not be voting to end the pensions triple
lock pension should should not be paying
the price for the cost of living crisis
where they're caused by their war in
Ukraine or mini budgets so is that still
your position that you won't be voting
to end the pensions well I've been
pretty clear and uh you know it was in
our Manifesto to keep the the triple
lock and which she was also very clear
today that he's a prime minister that's
standing on that 2019 Manifesto and he
wants to deliver it now of course you
know we can't have a running commentary
on the fiscal announcement that's going
to be happening uh on the 17th of
November and what what worries me is
that when the government doesn't confirm
one way or the other the speculation
amounts and vacuums created and people
start to worry and I've got pensioners
who are worried but the chancellor only
last week said he was committed to the
triple lock
um and given that Rishi said today at
Prime Minister's questions that he's
standing on the 29 2019 Manifesto I'm
hoping that means that the triple lock
is in place but we will know for sure on
the 17th of November you're right aren't
you that it is you know constituents
like yours and around the country this
kind of chopping and changing is quite
concerning you know on the 2nd of
October Liz trust committed to the
pensions triple lock on the 18th of
October so drop that commitment on the
19th of October she then recommitted to
the triple lock and now on the 26th of
October University neck isn't confirming
whether that is going to be there or not
I mean it's really uncertain isn't it
well to be fair to this trust you didn't
actually ever drop the commitment to the
triple lock she just didn't confirm what
was going to be in or out of the the
kind of the Halloween uh statement that
we were expecting and you know it's the
same for the government now they've got
some big decisions to make they're going
to have to meet with every Secretary of
State go through their budgets look at
the forecast as well and make some some
key challenges they're not going to
preempt that but that doesn't mean if
they can't confirm today that it's not
going to be there you know Rishi said at
the dispatch box the 2019 Manifesto
stands then I'm hoping that means the
triple lock is staying now you of course
weren't a fan of the Liz trust's
Premiership you said that she should
resign
um how much damage do you think she's
done to the conservative party well you
know I think Liz went in with the best
of intentions I supported Rishi with his
initial campaign and he did warn that
some of the decisions while we all want
to see lower taxes for people all that
if you're having to borrow to do that or
you're not able to explain where that
funding is coming from to support that
it will spook the markets and that that
unfortunately I don't want to be right
I'm sure she didn't want to be right
either but that's unfortunately what
happened and I'm less worried about what
it's done to the conservative party I'm
more worried what it's done to the
country as a whole and what happened
well you know I know from constituents
who are either renting or have mortgages
who and that's you know their main
concern is about interest rates going up
how they'll pay those those monthly
increases and the significant energy
price support package that was put in
that will be saving people thousands of
pounds a year from energy bills that
could have gone up to three four five
thousand pounds was dwarfed by some of
the fears around mortgage interest rates
some of the interest rates are now
coming back down because the market has
confidence in Richie and Jeremy Hunt as
the chancellor but I think the the fear
that it's put into people I think you
know that will take a while to as Rishi
said to regain that trust I mean you'll
see isn't the safest it never has been
though you do face a bit of a challenge
there particularly from the lib Dems um
how worried are you well you know I was
never predicted to win my seat in 2015.
um you know I overturned an 8 000
majority I was expected to lose in 2017
in 2019 it was a remain seat I you know
it's voted for brexit and of course you
know seats like mine are always going to
be predicted but actually I think uh
what people are saying to me on the
doorstep is that they just want some
stability they just want a government
that will get on with the job and we'll
deal with their fears whether that's
mortgage rates or whether that's just
paying the bills or putting food on the
table they want the government just to
get on with the job now and politicians
to stop bickering and start working okay
thank you very much good to see you on
the show at Miracle field there well
kirst armor says that Rishi sunak has no
mandate from the people and should call
a general election and he also
criticized a new PM in the Commons
earlier for the reappointment of sowella
bravaman as we've been discussing while
laborers at Shadow International
Development Minister pre-core Gayle
joins us now live great to have you on
the program today so do you think that
Rishi CNET will be a better prime
minister than Liz truss
well look I thought Rishi had the
opportunity to come to the pmqs and
really sort of show that there's a break
from the past I mean that is very
difficult because of course he was the
chancellor there but I think what was
surprising was the kind of Johnson Diggs
that he resorted to and that was quite
cheap I think because here was an
opportunity for him to answer some
questions and to put some of those uh
you know beers especially around the
appointment of zuela government we know
that this was a grubby deal as care
called it to get the right wing of the
party
um on side but I think what's really
concerning is did he override uh the
decision you know and the concerns
raised with him uh by Simon case for
example and given that this is National
Security surely Rishi should be putting
the country first and not his party and
what he's actually shown is nothing has
really changed just changing you know
some of the seats at the top doesn't
mean to say we've we've broken away and
actually they've learned any lessons and
understood where the British public are
um so I think it's really quite
concerning uh at these early uh sort of
days uh Rishi sunach I guess would say
that Luke solar Brotherman made an error
of judgment she recognized it she
accepted her mistake it's the policies
that mattered do you think he's got a
point
no I don't because like I said this is
about National Security being the Home
Secretary you will have sensitive
information and the Very fact that she
breached the ministerial cold you know
it's absolutely right that our shadow
homosexual event Cooper is calling for
an investigation we do need to know what
information she did share how sensitive
the nature of that information is this
is really important we need somebody in
this role that understands that National
Security cannot be compromised at any uh
you know at any point and I don't think
that this shows any confidence even in
the prime minister at the choice of his
Home Secretary and the Very fact that
actually he stood there making his
speech saying that he was going to have
integrity and professionalism in the way
he conducts himself and then what what
did we see five hours later here Point
swallow government I don't think that
gives any of us any confidence another
appointment that he did make is Andrew
Mitchell you of course with your
International Development hat on he's a
new Minister for International
Development now here's someone who has
consistently talked about the importance
of funding for age you know he backed
the commitment to spend 0.7 of GDP on
Aid are you glad to see him in post
I really welcome Andrew Mitchell coming
into the post I think it's really
important that the merger has been
absolutely catastrophic it's been
catastrophic catastrophic for the
foreign office it's been catastrophic
for the development uh you know
expertise that we had in terms of uh
diffid and the most importantly though
it's our reputation that has been
tatters for the very first time I've
seen our allies in the United States uh
head of usaid Samantha power be very
very critical about Britain's uh role in
terms of Naval gazing during a pandemic
restructuring Whitehall departments
taking over superpower of development
that the world absolutely had huge
amounts of respect and then of course
embarking on Aid cuts and these Cuts
matter because they didn't need to
happen at the time when you know we what
we've now seen is Rishi sunak writing
off 11 billion pounds of fraud we saw
all of the crony contracts we saw all
the wastage with the PPE billions and
billions of pounds of taxpayers money uh
that this government has squandered with
no regard for it no at respect so I
really look forward to holding Andrew to
account actually on all the things that
he and the back Ventures were saying
about this government and about why it
mattered it's in our national interest
let's not forget
um people understood during the pandemic
that local Health was Global health and
the solidarity that the British public
has seen is something that this
government just does not understand so
yes I welcome this appointment I look
forward to working with Andrew of course
holding him to account as well now Rishi
Scenic of course the first British Asian
prime minister and I just want
now at a tweet that was deleted by Nadia
with him who's the labor MP this tweet
says Rishi sunak as prime minister isn't
a win for Asian representation he is a
multi-millionaire who is chancellor cut
taxes on Bank profits while overseeing
the biggest drop in living standards
since 1956. black white or Asian if you
work for a living he is not on your side
do you know if it's true that kirstama
asked her to delete the Tweet do you
know if that's right
well Thursday can I just say I don't
agree with Maddie and I think it's
absolutely right that she deleted that
tweet this is a really significant and
historical moment for our country the
fact that we have uh Rishi who comes
from an Indian Heritage but of course
his family his parents were born in East
Africa uh you know it just shows um to
the many many uh millions of children in
this country growing up that actually if
you dream big and and you follow your
aspirations then yes there is the
opportunity for you to become Prime
Minister of this country
um so I think it's really significant
but we will we will judge Rishi on his
past actions and his future actions as
prime minister and that is what we will
hold to account but I have to say um I'm
pleased that Nadia you know withdrew
those comments and understood that
actually was not appropriate does not
reflect the labor party in any uh shape
or form and certainly wasn't My Views
all peers is it disappointing to you
that the conservatives have had the
first female and the first non-white
prime minister
well look I mean I think it's uh they've
been in power for a very long time of
course we've been in opposition uh we've
been in a very difficult Place uh in the
sort of last five years and I think what
Kia has done and he should be given
credit for is actually really uh turned
the party around so it's forward-facing
outward looking
um and it's building the confidence uh
within the country giving us a hearing
and I think that was the absolute uh
right thing to do it's uh and I don't
think sometimes he's given enough credit
to where he's actually shifted us so I
think you know sometimes it's about
situational it's about where the party
is at how do we move forward and Care
was a white person at the right time to
take us there and but let's not forget
our front bench is built with fantastic
brilliant women we've got a vet keeper
um you know Rachel Reeves uh there's
some fantastic women leading uh on our
front bench so I think you know yes we
absolutely have got to make sure we uh
you know appoint a woman as leader in
the future I have no doubt that there is
some fantastic women lots of talent uh
that would want to do that but I think
this moment in this juncture for the
labor party here is the absolute Right
leader and he's the person that needs to
be our next prime minister and that's
why we need a general election okay
you're going to squeeze in the general
election call at some point during the
interview uh thank you very much for
being on the program tonight thank you
thanks so much
well let's try and work out should we
what we've learned so far we're joined
as usual on the show bear Deputy
political editor at soundcode Sam you
know before the program we were having a
chat weren't we about you know what is
the big story today and it feels like
the news cycle has been so mad frankly
that there's always been a clear story
but it didn't there's been a bit of a
shift somehow that's right because we
didn't know the answer to that question
I went over to the houses of Parliament
for the last couple of hours just to
take the temperature and there's just a
sort of great feeling of MPS exhaling I
mean it's been pandemonium for the last
well really since everybody got back in
early September
um and I think that tells you quite a
lot about what they feel like that where
particularly Tories feel that they've
reached today they feel like The Madness
of the truss era brief 49-day era is at
an end and they've replaced it with
somebody who exudes uh calmness
incompetence uh but also somebody who
did what they weren't sure he could do
which is to basically carry
um or at least sort of perform to that
satisfaction in prime minister's
questions and I think um showing that he
had a bit more Zing about him I think
has been a great relief at for Tory MPS
and there's something else that's quite
interesting that's going on tonight
Sophie which is that those that weren't
hanging around to see if the phone rang
to see if they get back in the new
government are actually on their way
home because there's no real important
business tomorrow and next week key
bills like the online harms bill and the
strike Bill both of which quite
contentious has actually been delayed
probably not scrapped but uh probably
just kicked off into the distance and
the thing is I think you're going to see
a bit of this
um during the late Cameron and early
Theresa May years when there was
difficulties afoot that actually the
business managers the chief whip of the
time would empty out the commons would
send MPS home would ensure that there
wasn't much business and I and the
architect of that was Gavin Williamson
an individual now back in government and
I think we're going to see far more days
with the common slightly less busy than
it otherwise would have been because the
biggest danger to Rishi sunak is his own
party so why bring them to Westminster
are you looking forward to quite a time
or are you someone who wants to be busy
all the time never and don't worry lots
of challenges ahead not least the mini
budget in about three weeks time so we
will be visiting the good news uh Sam
thanks very much uh you are watching uh
the take we are live here in Westminster
for you up next we'll be talking to
Caroline Lucas about the new prime
minister's decision to reinstate the ban
on fracking
[Music]
[Music]
that has happened in minutes and now
it's coming from both sides and it's
moving this way
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
for the people here before praying
quietly to themselves I'm Alex Crawford
and I'm Skye's special correspondent
based in Istanbul
now they're trying to finish the job off
[Music]
okay it's okay don't worry it's okay
they're becoming very sensitive
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
every time they touch them they spray
spray
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients made
for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain
worlds I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
as we pick our prime minister's question
of the week so the one that really
caught our eye during the session
earlier and today it's this one
the prime minister's Reckless
predecessor took a wrecking ball to
Nature prompting millions of members of
the rspb The National Trust and the
wildlife trust to rise up in opposition
yesterday he promised to fix her
mistakes as well as to uphold the
party's 2019 Manifesto so if he is a man
of his word will he start by reversing
the green light she gave to fracking
since it's categorically not been shown
to be safe and instead maintain the
moratorium that was pledged in that very
moratoric in that very Manifesto that he
has promised to uphold
I I I've already said I stand by the
manifesto on that but what I would say
is that I'm proud that this government
has passed the landmark environment tag
putting more protection for the national
environment than we've ever had with a
clear plan to deliver and I can give the
honorable lady my commitment that we
will deliver on all those Ambitions we
will deliver on what we said at cop
because we care deeply about passing our
children an environment in better State
than we found it ourselves
well there we go something quite rare at
promises questions we've got a policy
update from the Prime Minister the
fracking ban is back now that question
was posed by Caroline Lucas of the green
party MP for Brighton and she joins us
now
Carolyn Lucas clapping a conservative
prime minister who would have thought to
have seen that in the House of Commons
yes I don't think it's going to happen
often but on that particular issue I
think that Common Sense has prevailed
you know it was always an obsessional
ideologically driven program from
jacobi's Rog and and Liz truss in order
to go for fracking when we know that
there's no evidence that it can get our
fuel bills down our energy bills down at
least because any gas that was fracked
would simply be sold on global markets
International prices it wouldn't come on
stream for a very long time so it would
do nothing in terms of energy Security
in the short term either and of course
it's also linked to driving the climate
emergency not least because the methane
emissions that are linked to uh fractal
gas mean that actually fracked gases
worse for the environment than natural
gas so the planet can't handle it people
don't want it and I'm glad that Rishi
cnack saw that today I guess what some
like such as Liz truss would say is that
at a time when you know energy bills are
soaring we need to look at our energy
security use a dependence on oil and gas
from Russia we need to diversify all
over the place so you know whether it's
fracking onshore wind offshore wind
nuclear even North Sea oil as a
transitional fuel do you think they've
got a point
I don't think they've got a point if
they think that fracked gas is somehow
going to help us address that immediate
energy crisis I mean you're quite right
we do need to diversify Supply and we
also need to put Energy Efficiency right
at the top of the agenda and I think one
of the frustrating things is that the
government and successive Tory
governments over the past 12 years have
totally failed to put in place the most
obvious thing which is the local
authority-led Street by Street home
insulation program which could really
protect people this winter and make sure
that they're not using their scarce
resources to be heating the outside
instead of heating their homes
um the thing about fracking is that it's
not going to get you the gas anytime
soon so even after three years you might
be looking at about one percent that you
might be displacing through your
domestic gas rather than imported gas
and I come back to the point that even
as kwaziquitang himself said when he was
the business and energy Minister there
is no guarantee that gas fract in the UK
will be sold in the UK as quatang said
you know energy companies aren't
Charities they are going to sell it to
the highest bidder and that's not
necessarily someone in the UK so it
doesn't help our energy security and it
does Drive greater climate change
um I'm interested to get your thoughts
on another you know Green issue if you
like those hit the headlines recently
the just stop oil protesters they had
that of course a very well covered uh
protest where they threw tomato soup
over Van Gogh's sunflowers paintings at
the National Gallery what was your
reaction to that do you think that it's
legitimate because it got that point
raised or did you look at it and think
actually that doesn't really sit well
with me
well the first thing I would say is the
right to peaceful protest is under
massive attack from uh this government
um so far rashish unak hasn't indicated
he's going to withdraw the public uh
Bill office the the public bill
um public order bill is what I'm trying
to say sorry the public order bill which
um criminalizes trespass and and
criminalizes um protests so that's the
first point on on the um on those
particular actions personally my own
preference would be to Target
um those things that are more directly
linked to the issue that the protesters
are are concerned about so for example
more recently they have been targeting
55 tufton Street which is where many of
the global warming denier groups are
based and that to me tells a clearer
story so that is my own personal
preference but I'm not going to
criticize other people who are frankly
driven to taking this kind of action
because they can see that the vehicle is
is careering towards a cliff Edge and
they are going to do anything they can
to try to rest the the steering wheel
and try and avoid what is a a massive
massive Cliff Edge let's not forget the
ipcc the intergovernmental panel on
climate change themselves have said that
we have a brief uh uh just a very brief
time in order to uh be able to address
the climate crisis a brief fund and
rapidly closing window for a livable
future is actually what they say and I
think given that context then we need to
get a bit of proportion and make sure
that we're protecting nature itself as
well as the pictures of it given you
know your clear concerns and your
long-standing concerns about the
environment what do you think a Rishi
sunak Premiership is going to mean for
you know the green agenda
well I am worried notwithstanding the
fact that he did the right thing today
on on fracking I mean we've given no
indication that he will reverse for
example the plans to uh rip up 570
pieces of of EU derived environmental
legislation uh this was a bill that was
being debated in the Commons yesterday
um and if it goes ahead it means there's
an artificial Cliff Edge a sunset Clause
that means that by the end of next year
if if we haven't transposed more of that
uh legislation and and put it into UK
law more firmly then it will just simply
drop and the legislation we're talking
about is the legislation to try to keep
our beaches cleaner it's legislation to
try and keep our Rivers clean this this
really matters
um and the idea that you would simply uh
ensure that Jeffrey would ask defra the
department for the environment to
somehow go through 570 pieces of
legislation in in just over a year seems
to me to be bizarre and we know there
simply isn't the capacity in that
department to do it so when it comes to
Nature I'm worried when it comes to yet
more oil and gas from the North Sea I'm
worried so he's going to have to do an
awful lot I think to be able to win back
the the support of for example the
members of The National Trust or the
rspb who who just in recent weeks have
been threatening to to rise up in the
streets because they are so concerned
about what the conservative government
has been doing okay Caroline Lucas are
always good to talk good to have you in
the program
thank you
Caroline Lucas there you're watching the
take we're live as always on a Wednesday
night in Westminster up next we are
going to have a closer look at Rishi cnx
very first premises questions
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back just before we get to
our usual at pmqs at slot in the program
just to bring you the readout that we've
just had through from Downing streets
about the prime minister's call with the
European commission president Ursula Von
de Lyon this evening they stress the
importance on the relationship as usual
they also talked about the United
response to the Russian invasion of
Ukraine and agreed that the UK and EU
have much in common not least the
challenges we are facing in areas like
the economy and climate change and
resolve to work closely on those issues
this are quite important though so on
the Northern Ireland protocol the Prime
Minister restated his preference for
exploring a negotiated solution to the
current issues so perhaps at their
desire from Russia to try and find a
negotiated solution with the EU to the
current issues on the Northern Ireland
protocol
now Tony Blair once called promises
questions nerve-wracking
discombobulating nail biting bowel
movementing Terror inspiring courage
draining well Rishi Cena face that
experience for the very first time today
in just his second day in the job here's
what our political correspondent Joe
Pike made of it in pmq's unwrapped
Rishi sunak is the most inexperienced
parliamentarian to become Prime Minister
in decades and that is because his rise
has been astronomically Swift Just seven
years between entering the commons and
entering number 10 a far shorter period
than many of his predecessors just look
at the last three between 12 and 19
years they had to wait Gordon Brown had
to wait 24 years one man is missing from
this list that is of course David
Cameron he waited for nine years before
becoming prime minister and one of those
who helped him and later Boris Johnson
prepare for their weekly parliamentary
joust was Michael Gove who he spotted at
7 26 this morning arriving at number 10
for a pmq's prep session later he
perched by the speaker's chair to watch
his latest student
take any lectures Mr Gove seemed to have
supplied Mr sunak with a series of Boris
Johnson's Greatest Hits attacking labor
on everything from Jeremy corbyn to
brexit
from the person who tried to overturn
the biggest democratic
he was supporting the member for
Islington North the party opposite will
be backing The Lunatic protesting Fringe
I know the right honorable gentleman
rarely Leaves North London we won't take
any lectures on National Security Mr
Speaker kirstama zeroed in on the
reappointment of suela bravaman as Home
Secretary just six days after she was
sacked from that role for sharing secret
documents we can all see what's happened
here he's so weak he's done a grubby
deal trading National Security because
he was scared to lose another leadership
election there's a new Tory at the top
but as always with them party first
country second the PM said she had
apologized for her mistakes but dodged
the question over where the senior civil
servants had advised him not to give her
the job she soon act faced barbs about
his wealthy wife's tax Arrangements I
don't need to explain to the Prime
Minister how non-dom status Works he
already knows all about that and his own
wealth a nurse would have to work over
20 000 years in order to match the vast
wealth of this prime minister and
notably in many of his answers he used
the c word compassion
of our compassionate compassionate
compassionate party while Mr sunac's
team will be delighted with his debut
the best joke was surely this from sakir
starmer
even his own side now he's not on the
side of working people that why the only
time he ran in a competitive election he
he's
I was watching from the Press gallery
and aside from after that gag the sheer
booming volume of the cheers from the
conservative benches was striking we've
not seen that for a long time certainly
today's head-to-head seemed to force
both leaders to up their game
I'd just say I agree with Joe Pike's
analysis there it did feel like both men
raising their game at in pmqs today but
what did people watching on Sky News
make of all the most important people uh
because uh Rishi sunak had to pitch the
party well now he's got to pitch the
country so let's bring in our viewers
panel uh shall we uh great to see
everyone uh tonight now my producer
Jared when he was talking to you earlier
asked you to write down a word that
comes into your mind when you hear Rishi
Scenic and I'm really interested to know
what that word is if you've got a piece
of paper with you can you just hold up
to the screen so I can try and read it
so we have unelected
I'm struggling to read the second one
I'll come back to you stabilizing I can
see disappointing evasive and determined
optimistic is the second one so a bit of
a spread a bit of a spread really
interesting to hear some of those views
let's get your views in a bit more uh
detail now shall we let's go to is our
battery charger first now you're a 27
year old you're a lib Dem slash labor
voter you're in London you said that you
were to describe British unac is
unelected tell us more
yeah I think he's definitely more
competent than this trust or or even
Boris and I think that's good for the
country overall but I think ultimately
he's being kind of forced to to build
back the conservative fiscal credibility
by doing what will probably be very
extreme Public Services Cuts in the next
budget I think the the hole he has to
fill is allegedly like 35 billion pounds
and as much as he can say compassion he
doesn't have a mandate for those cuts he
didn't win with the conservative base
and he's definitely not one with a
country and so when he makes those
difficult decisions I'm not sure where
he's getting kind of the legitimacy to
do that from okay uh really interesting
to hear uh so a bit of a kind of I guess
a
a different view balanced view more
competent but worried about the cuts to
come right let's bring in eroica Saint
John malbay shall we you describe
yourself as a center-left uh voter
you're talking to us from Norfolk talk
to us about the new prime minister what
do you make of him
well um I thought this recent nomination
process was the diversity Quest too far
for the
um Tory Grassroots population
um and that's why Liz press came in and
that's time wasted for the Tory party
um if
now we're here I think if Rishi is going
to be genuinely
compassionate and fair that word was
banded around a lot then great but the
Tory party's been very very ruthless on
the British population uh brutal in fact
and it's beginning to feel a lot like
serfdom okay
um
so
I think everybody's very bruised and and
it has been shambles it it's all to play
for but it's we are tired
from uh right let's bring in um let's
bring in Tim Chapman shower you're
talking to us from Scotland what do you
make of a Rishi scenic
uh I've liked him so far I think he's
proved to be stabilizing the markets I'm
hoping he can stabilize the decline of
the target party uh and not having
watched him at pmqs today
um I think he could have some common
sense and normality back to politics
which I think we all need
right so positive view there uh from uh
you uh Tim let's bring in Lisa uh Lisa
Goddard are you you're a regular on the
program and we know you're a labor voter
you've been pretty disappointed with
some of the conservatives so far and you
said you're disappointed with she's seen
that too
I I have a great love and respect for
Hinduism and the Hindu community and I
had a lot of Hope yesterday when I saw
uh Rishi uh on the steps but then when
he announced his cabinet and uh when
I've seen him in Parliament pmqs today
it was just like a rerun of Boris
Johnson it was like pull out all the old
things that we say that get the back
benches to to shout and cheer and it was
just I was just was very disappointed
just disappointed disappointed from Lisa
right let's bring in Mike Monroe at
shall we you say you're a swing voter
perhaps turning more towards the right
you're talking to us from Hampshire now
I was interested to hear that you used
to live in British sunax constituency so
you've had a little bit of a
correspondence with him tell us more
yes I used to I used to write to him
regularly
um but what I found the reason I used
the word evasive
today I found him evasive on the
bravaman issue and on the issue of the
video that he did
um
uh where he boasted about moving funds
from deprived areas to rich areas
didn't answer the question
and my experience of him was I I queried
the thing about 20
000 police
um saying hey you what you've seen to
forget is you laid off the Tories
governments laid off 20 000 police and a
lot of
police Administration that supports the
police
and you're talking about oh with this
great thing where we're going to recruit
20 000 police
well how much did it cost to lay people
off and then to recruit new people you
just wasted a whole load of money for
what ideological reasons okay yeah
interesting well good to hear that you
got response at least but as you say
perhaps a few concerns after that pmqs
uh still right let's talk now finally to
Bruce Tyler your conservative voter East
Riding of Yorkshire is where you're
talking to us from
what'd you make of Rich you see Mac
well I think he's the uh right person
for the job as far as a conservative
party are concerned
um there wasn't too much uh too much
choice to be had I think Penny mordant
was um she's from the right wing of the
party when I think the party needed a
more Centrist figure and she hadn't got
a lot of top level government experience
um and Boris Johnson well a return to
government by him I think would have
been more laughable than uh Bobby Ewing
returning to Dallas so he is the best
man for the job and I think he's made a
reasonable start I think he had a good
performance in the prime minister's
question time today but I do think he's
made a mistake um in the reappointment
of swella bravaman really interesting I
have to say it feels like overall people
think British United Improvement on Liz
trust some more uh positive than others
but perhaps that appointment of Zoella
Brotherman not going down too well with
our panel Greg's torture world really
interesting thank you very much you're
watching the take live in Westminster up
next we're going to be rounding up
everything we've heard doing a bit of
post-match analysis with some codes and
Ed Conway we're spoiled this evening
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Sky's Chief correspondent well there's a
real sense now that people are beginning
to expect that this whole airlift is
coming to an end and they're really
really desperate
for snatch words going in grabbing
people and putting putting trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover or you die
okay so that's like a wall That's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
for the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
Venezuela is eager for change we've been
crushed
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world they were convinced the
United States would become hooked we're
all right
we're normal six station has just come
down I think it's a monster just landed
in between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in Iraq and
Syria but across the world
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well we've had
plenty of takes this evening we're gonna
have a bit of post-match round up with
our in-house experts first we're joined
Again by adaptive political editor Sam
coach we've also got economics editor Ed
Conway at the Sky News Center too but
let's start with Sam shall we
so let's just kind of
have an overall look shall we've got the
new prime minister Rishi sunak
um what do we know about him what kind
of Premium do we expect 42 years old the
first Prime Minister younger than me in
my lifetime uh the first British Asian
prime minister the first uh Hindu uh
active uh Faith there you see him
popping into a Downing Street um Hindu
reception to celebrate Diwali and I
think that has resonated not just here
in the UK but around the world and cross
parties
absolutely it is an important moment I
think uh for lots of people
um as people come to terms with yet
another prime minister somebody that
they really didn't didn't know a huge
amount about apart from during the
pandemic and Richardson of course came
in all of a sudden
um replacing Santa Javed as prime
minister back in the early days of Boris
Johnson and was there uh taking us
through the pandemic author of the
furlough scheme which will be the thing
that he's most recognized for but of
course
um as a politician it was a very rapid
ascent and he comes from a business
background some wondering just how in
touch he is and fabulous photos from
back in March now he just put up in
whatever fiscal event mini budget that
day I mean just knocked 5p off uh the
price of a pint of um Fuel and here he
is filling up a car but as we later
learned this is somebody else's car
because he'd gone to a new cross petrol
station but then even worse if we look
at the next slide we can see how he
tried to use his contactless card with a
barcode scanner and then announced that
he didn't really know how to use
contactless and that was just before the
leadership contest prompting some to
wander quite how in touch he is Rishi
sunak really has forged his reputation
as somebody who gives away a huge amount
of money uh tens of billions of pounds
to the public the challenge now in a
matter of weeks is where we can start
cutting and remain popular yeah that
really is uh the challenge great photos
thanks very much Sam always good to talk
right let's talk now shall we to our
economics editor Ed Conway because
really so much of Russia students
Premiership is going to be defined by
the economy in the long term and in the
short term what the markets are doing
what are the early signs Ed
well it's actually worth just saying you
know we've just had this news that
they're going to be delaying this
medium-term fiscal plan as it was going
to be called it's not going to come next
week it's going to come a few weeks
later that's really interesting because
it's a function of what's been going on
recently in financial markets and
remember we're going to be talking a lot
about black holes in the next few weeks
part of this is the size of the black
hole is defined by just what's going on
in markets at any given time and because
markets in particular government debt
markets we're going haywire recently the
interest rates were really high that
meant that the size of that black hole
was looking really really big and part
of the reason this is the interesting
thing part of the reason it's been
delayed isn't just so it gives them a
bit more time isn't just so they can
actually look as if they're not
necessarily an emergency mode anymore
it's also because it saves them
potential room it means they don't have
to do as much cutting as they might
otherwise have had to do because the
black hole might not be so big and
that's all because markets are going to
be a bit calmer or at least look like
they're red camera at the moment and
they can then bake that into the a
future forecasts so that's consequential
for all of us it really matters and
we'll hear more about it in the next few
weeks
thank you so much always good to get
your take Ed thanks for squeezing Us in
that is it for this week on the take
we'll be back next week and every week
Wednesday at 9 00 p.m thanks very much
for watching
[Music]